Anthony O'Neil Ramsey personality number
one best-selling author and dr. John
Delaney Ramsey personality and
professional two PhDs one in counseling
including crisis management join me for
a special hour this hour something we
don't usually do we spend 98% of our
time on this show dealing with life and
money so we talk about stuff like
marriages and kids and money and
business leadership and we're not afraid
of social issues we're not lacking on
opinions on social issues it's just not
our job it's that simple but I began
getting criticism for not speaking out
on the murder of George Floyd last week
and then of course Anthony did too for
those of you don't know Anthony's
african-american if you're listening on
the radio on YouTube it's fairly obvious
but um but uh so he wasn't loud enough
to suit some of his brothers or sisters
in that community and quick enough on
the draw does have a statement on that
and now on the riots as well and and of
course in our culture today anyone who
has a platform anyone who is in the
spotlight is expected to speak up and
agree with you whoever you are and then
if they don't agree with you then you
don't like them anymore
and you don't watch their movies or
listen to their show or buy their books
or whatever and that's just not the
business we're in if we were doing
political talk radio it would be the
flavor of the day and we would spend all
our time dealing with this stuff but we
are going to take an hour of the 15
hours of radio that I will do that will
be done here this week and talk about
this issue of the evils of racism the
horrible thing that you know Amada
Aubrey goes for a jog it gets killed and
this happens too much and nobody in this
building is okay with that as a matter
of fact most nobody in the US is okay
with it but it's not there's nothing
being done about it
and so Anthony on that you had a
wonderful post at seven a half minutes
long if you haven't guys haven't seen it
on over the weekend you did speak up and
even that wasn't good enough for some
folks I just put a fairly innocuous
Twitter out that you know the killing of
George Floyd was awful
riding is awful but now I'm a racist
because of that apparently which I don't
understand at all but let's talk about
this for a minute let's start with you
you know Dave one of the main reasons
why it took me you know a few days to
post something about it is because like
you said that's not really my fight and
I am not really moving fast enough
because I want to make sure that when I
do speak up when I do have a voice and
I'm saying the right thing and also
backing it up with action and so being
black I mean as it's clear as day this
is bothers me it well sure it I'm upset
I'm angry I'm nervous when I see George
when I see Aubree I see my brother I
only have one blood brother I get
nervous I see my nephews and I have two
nephews who are growing up right now
feeling Araya
male nephews and I get nervous and it
bothers me that that this could happen
to not just myself but to any of my
loved ones and it has been happening in
the past and it's time for it to change
and it bothers me that this is happening
we need change but I think the thing
that has really been bothering me here
lately over the last couple of days it's
just being attacked because you know I'm
supposedly connected to our races and so
that would be me and and when they
attack you know you are connected to a
supposed race yeah which is absolutely
asinine by those hey really I mean
because I mean let's look at the Ramsey
personalities okay there are two white
women two white men and two black guys
well Dave you're really good at
diversity no don't insult them I heard
the best people for the job I didn't
look at their skin color
I didn't look at their sex Rachael Cruz
is a world-class communicator and
speaker there's nothing to do that with
the fact that she's female
Anthony O'Neill can hold a stage and
mesmerize people it has nothing to do
they don't know go WOW there's a black
guy now I have to pay attention no they
pay attention because this guy's a
thought leader and delivers so the idea
that there's anything racist and this
organization is asinine yeah yeah it
really is but I think America needs to
hear here I say this and clearly hear me
say this what happened to not just -
George - Ahmad - Brianna tell it to all
these people now was wrong
but as pass wrong horribly it was wrong
and it needs to change and stop and I
get why people are mad yeah I mean
somebody was attacking my family yeah
man my hillbilly come out I'd be mad you
know somebody was tacking you know if I
thought like you're talking about your
nephew yeah which I know your nephews
yes so no your wonderful family but if I
thought somebody was attacking my kids
our Father was visualizing that that
could happen to one of my grandbabies
what's happening like you're visualizing
that there man that'll make you mad I'll
make you mad at a deepest part of your
soul I get that I completely understand
that it hurts it hurts it really does
and I was in tears and and I had a good
talk with you know just a couple of my
african-american friends and just really
just hearing us out and you know and
devar I want to thank you for hearing me
out
hearing your african-american workers
out here because what the world thinks
about you with some of the world thinks
about you it's completely false you are
not who they think you are as far as in
being races so that's clear as day but I
do I do understand that the world is
angry that they're upset and I started
this is not about me that's not I
appreciate that but this is I mean
people are hurting and they're scared
and generally around racism John we're
talking about this
there's we're coming up on a break so
I'm but I'm gonna open a thought and let
you
come back and you guys talk about it
racism is obviously ignorance regardless
of which direction it's pointed you know
it is obviously there's a lot of fear
around it's almost like fear of the
unknown because of the because you're
ignorant and also within this hour I
want to ask you guys and maybe even some
of our callers chime in I'm not going to
get I'm not gonna start a poll on
whether you think this is right or
that's right I don't wanna do that you
know we we don't have any answers mm-hmm
here but we we've observed a few
instances when things work the way
they're supposed to and in many
instances where they didn't and so I'm
kind of thinking I don't want solution
this because I don't I'm not I'm not a
policy maker
I'm not Gandhi I'm not MLK I'm not on
that level I'm not that guy but I mean
there are to be something we can learn
from going through kovat yeah oughta be
something we can learn from going
through this so that we can you know
because if ignorance is the problem the
knowledge is the solution right and
relationships yeah that's what I mean
fear not the relationships is that is
the issue yeah it's exactly the issue so
we're going to talk about at this hour
this is the Dave Ramsey show we're
talking about racism and riots and some
of the stuff that's in the news stuff we
don't usually talk about this our may
open up the phones in a minute if I come
up with an intelligent question to ask
that might elicit an intelligent
response but I don't want a bunch of
hyperbole if you don't know what that is
it's drama without thinking which is
what a whole bunch of people are doing
right now and so I'm not going to get
into that but let's go back to where we
left off going into the break so I grew
up in Tennessee in Nashville Tennessee
in the 60s I was a six years old in 1966
eight years old in 1968 the
assassination of Bobby Kennedy the
assassination of Martin Luther King and
I grew up in a lily-white suburban
neighborhood with a bunch of guys a
bunch of white guys off the farm and so
some of them or
racists some of them were not in the
neighborhood the men in the neighborhood
the women in the neighborhood
and so I grew up around that there were
african-american kids in our school from
day one and so I grew up and what I'm
leading to is is the more I have
traveled the more my experiences outside
of my original group have expanded the
more racism that that was whatever level
of racism was planted for a kid in the
60s in the South has been destroyed
because you can't meet intelligent
wonderful caring loving Christian people
of another race of another country and
get to know them and like you said going
to break build relationships without it
dissipating without it lowering the Razr
the only way to maintain racism is to
stay in a whole group of stupid people
that believe one thing and you never get
outside that group but if you get
outside that group it starts to
dissipate you agree with that yeah it's
it's it's it's actually a brain
chemistry thing when when you get scared
or lonely your brain quickly divides the
world up into us as and limbs and then
it does what it can to perpetuate that
and now we live in an ecosystem where
our I'm pointing at your laptop Dave or
my laptop here I'll close that you don't
Witter 200 which is proof on brain
damage but what it does is now we have a
new system that gives us the news that
we already it tells us what we already
think and what we already want to know
and it just makes it deeper and deeper
so we're now able to live and I call
them art our trash cans are stupid I
don't have to look anybody here from any
different perspectives I'll have to talk
to you might have to share meals anybody
I could just live in my own little hole
and you're exactly right the only way
the only way to turn your brain off is
to start making relationships and
connections with other people
and I think it can be insulting to say
you know what Nathan II I I looked at my
friend group
I'm missing a black guy so would you be
right that's ridiculous right social
engineering things it gets ridiculous
but it goes back to how do you go be
about making relationships all across
the place how can you go about being
kind let that be your default setting
for a white guy like myself you what the
world doesn't need right now more of my
opinion and more of my my you know what
I think I need to listen I need to shut
my mouth I need to be quiet and I need
to listen I need to listen right I agree
and one of the things who I think
talking with you John as well is getting
the relationships like you and Dave said
but then also when you get into those
relationships and you hear something
that is off you ask the questions and
you sit down and you listen to the
answer right and you have a conversation
about that I've learned so much coming
here that I thought was like well that
wasn't that a racist statement and then
I asked Rachel are ask Dave and then
I'll get the explanation now I have
knowledge now I have understand your
example that's interesting I do you want
me to say it on the radio no I remember
the first time I heard you say redneck
and I was like whoa wait a minute
oh right about ten minutes after you met
me exactly and so redneck to me as a
black man that was a racist statement
and so I remember having a rednecks are
all racist - yes when I called myself a
redneck and then you thought oh my lord
I got myself into exactly and I
literally go back into this to the
office with Rachel I'm like Rach
what in the world like really and she
she taught me and and and let me know
exactly what does the word redneck mean
to you and to the average white person
where this out yeah so I'm like okay
because I was obviously I was offended
to be honest on your show I was like
whoa wait really like you I work for a
redneck and so in my head coming from
where I come from with this dude yes and
so I had to have a conversation
I have a relationship with you I have a
relationship with Rachel so I think what
you all are saying is so true is when
you get out of outside of your bubble
and you go into another world there's
gonna be some things that's gonna seem
all for seem wrong ask the question and
listen and ask more clarifying questions
and so when she said that I said I got
it now
I live around a bunch of rednecks
because I'm not in Columbia Tennessee
you know but I understand they're not
racist they're just southern white guys
who live out in the country or from the
country and I'm I'm cool with that
because I'm from the country that's why
I went out to the country because I love
living in the country but when I first
got here I have to be honest I thought
that was a racist state and interesting
and I was like I've heard the story yeah
you know what else you you added
something Dave so we've got recognized
your your where you feel like got a gap
in knowledge
number two you got to just be
relationships with people all over the
place and humbly listen but the third
thing you just mentioned that is so
critical is to be reflective and if if
there's a guy named Jordan bunch in
Texas who worked for me he was like 22
when I first hired him and I thought I
was smart and fancy and all this and I
said what's something you've been
practicing this isn't a one-on-one
meeting and he said something important
to me is whenever I get in a
disagreement with somebody the first
thing I do is I go look in the mirror
and say ask myself what did I bring to
this disagreement first and then I go
over here and so it's important that you
heard something you wouldn't ask
somebody and then you were reflective
right and that's the moment Terry real
says to skip your first feeling that
first that that impulse to fight right
or to say oh uh and just hear it hear it
and then be reflective step up above
that then or are to the other side of
that coin so to speak
what we're talking about is what brought
this discussion up is racism from whites
towards blacks primarily now there's
plenty of racism from blacks towards
whites
plenty of racism is when you you know
attribute a negative character quality
or a positive character quality to
someone because the color is color of
their skin
it's a straight-up ignorance I mean you
know to say that all Asian people are
good with math or something like that
that's just racism even though it's
positive character thing but it's just
it's I mean I know a guy
it's an Asian he's horrible math I mean
I know that that's not true the reason I
know that so I don't have that
stereotype so a stereotype is is what
we're dealing with here or there's you
know a certain race is has less
intelligence than another race or less
character or more prone to violence or
whatever and so when you attribute a
character quality based on skin color
that immediately makes you ignorant
right and the way to solve that
ignorance is actually interact with
people and get to know them and develop
a relationship yes of that other skin
color and then it starts to go white now
I don't know if this solves I don't know
I don't know how you do this on a macro
level or something
in terms of solving police misbehaving
and it's a small percentage of police
and it's a small percentage of the black
community well in in in but it's still
unbelievably painful right right right
and so scary right and and and then when
you grow up with an overview to where it
makes you say what you're saying earlier
like I think about my nephews yeah and
so it doesn't the small percentage has a
tremendous amount of leverage in this
discussion so it's almost like the
pendulum needs to swing so far the other
way where you overreact not in a
political correct politically correct
way but just to over do it over here to
make sure that everybody feels safe yeah
we back this is the Dave Ramsey show
we're doing something we don't usually
do on the Dave Ramsey show we're taking
a sidebar for an hour and talking a
social issue social issue is racism
because we're all angry horrified sad at
different levels and at different points
of understanding but we still have those
emotions
Anthony feels them at a different level
than maybe I do as an old guy Delon he's
a cooler guy than I am so he probably
feels them in a different level coming
off the college campus that kind of
stuff but if you your
not human if you think what happened I
mean your humanity is what I'm saying is
you have a more you have something
morally broken inside of you if you
think what happened to George Floyd is
okay or what happened to Ahmad Albert
Aubrey is okay and you know I think we
can just sit and say this just sucks and
don't have the answers but I do I'll
like back during kovat I kept telling
folks remain calm and try giving each
other a little grace try giving each
other a quick dance a dadgum mean to
each other and so it's bad enough that
this horrible thing happens but then on
top of that people are mean to each
other because of it horrible thing
happens people get sick but then people
are mean to each other because of it and
again that comes back to ignorant and
nuanced thinking meaning narrow
mindedness meaning that you you only
have one little set of thoughts because
you work with where you hang out with or
you grew up with and you never left your
little group and your little group is
the only thought you've ever had in your
brain and so that makes you ignorant of
the other groups anything we realize the
ignorance not lack of intelligence its
lack of knowledge anyone who has a
different opinion than you is
automatically dumb automatically evil
automatically erases an idiot right
automatically racist yeah saying and
when you play the race card or the
sexism card on everything where it
doesn't belong it starts to invalidate
it after a while and it's a valid card
it's the problem and so you don't want
to invalidate the card by calling
Anthony O'Neil racist that's kind of
like weird you know he's an
african-american guy it means kind of
actually how could he I mean yeah but I
mean I get how you could call me that I
get that although you'd be wrong but I
can at least grasp intellectually how
that could occur but I mean the it's the
ridiculousness of this has gone over the
top so we're talking about the but at
the break you you said you had a
question for Anthony yeah Anthony I in
the spirit of shutting my mouth and
the spirit of listening I got ten year
old little boy Hank I got a four year
old daughter Josephine
I've sat down I'm pretty open Hank and I
went went out yesterday and two days ago
and I walked him to there here's what's
happening here's the evil here's the the
role we have played here's a role we've
not played here's who we are here's were
gonna be going forth the the big
overarching question is like what do we
do if I am a white guy sitting in my
truck listening to this podcast and I
don't have a relationship with Anthony
on you can you give me a say this to
your kids say this in your home yeah man
I think the very first thing is to do
exactly what Dave just it's just say
this is wrong I mean one of the things
that I've learned with racism racism is
passed down from parents to kids when
they get older from parents to their
kids and so the very first thing I think
you have to do is just one check
yourself I'm like oh this is wrong and
had that conversation inside of your
home and explain to your son explain to
your daughter explained to your family
that what happened is wrong and this is
not what's happening in our house and we
love everyone for who they are for a
human being not because of the color of
their skin and answer the questions and
make sure that your kids understand what
what is racism and why you're not with
racism and how you're for a love and
expose them to to other other people Ken
Coleman or other personality here he and
I had the same conversation by his boys
at home about hey here's how you have
the conversation and now he's adopted
kids are african-american yes yes yes
and so they're young you know we have to
have a car honest conversation with them
and just explain to them and hey this is
this is wrong and explain to them why
it's wrong and then from there just
leave the conversation open and I will
just definitely say that teacher kids
not to be solid because when they go
inside the high schools when they go
inside their schools when they see their
african-american friends they need to be
able to say that was wrong
I'm sorry and it's show love and going
back to something Rachel Cruz says all
the time more is caught than taught
ability you can bark at your kids all
day right they're gonna watch you yes
they're gonna watch who you interact
with how you treat people and how you
respond how you talk about and watch
what you're saying around the house if
you're saying racial sayings and it may
not be your heart need to cut it you
need to stop that there were some words
that I would say back at home and I was
younger without saying here on the show
and my mom about us you know the n-word
you like don't say that around here hmm
that's not who you are and you do not
want to put that out there and so if
that's happening at the house any
anything that could be perceived
negative more is caught than taught you
know speak positive speak love and speak
the truth around your kids and then I
think um that's awesome
to me there's the thing I keep going
back to this idea and I guess it's a
personal experience
um and watching men and women in my
generation make a transition and it
wasn't because of political correctness
or social pressure or they felt like
they were going to be ostracized or be
arrested or something
they just started realizing this wrong
yeah I started changing yeah and then
they changed the next generation after
them and that always comes in my
experience and I keep going back to this
with this idea of I'm not gonna
tolerates what you're gonna have you
know and I'm not gonna have that in my
police department I'm not gonna have
that inside my company as for me and my
house yes I mean people aren't Ramsey
know they know don't you dare say
someone got the position or didn't get
the position because of race or sex or
anything else they got the position here
because by god they're the best at it
and don't you insult them otherwise you
get your you'll get your head butt
handed to you around here you do that
not just by me but other people in this
building we respect excellence and
nothing else and so if you can't do that
you're not one of us and I think you can
do that in a Police Department because
there are policemen law enforcement
people that I know personally well all
over this nation
that are incredibly good men and women
and the vast majority of them are but
there's a few turkey butts and them in
the mix that that need to be ejected by
the culture of the police department hmm
the culture of the law-enforcement
movement in general where that's not
okay and we've all run into really fine
law-enforcement people and I got to tell
you in my experience 99% of time I run
into them that's what I get now I know
that's my experience I get my
experiences different I understand yeah
I get that that's true though I do
I mean Anthony gets pulled over it's a
different experience and I get pulled
over yeah I mean I know that yes I know
that and thanks for saying it Dave but
but I mean you know but but the other
thing is I occasionally run into still
the guy who got a badge cuz he wanted to
be a be a you know he wouldn't be a bad
but yeah and so he has to prove that
he's somebody when pulls me over you
actually saw that happy one day I did I
did I was in the back of the car and
Mike you're riding with me we're going
to airport yeah and I just seen a guy
throw your ID back in on you and and
here's about I honestly say I said hello
I was gone cutting through a country
town going wide freaking opens four
o'clock in the morning we're trying to
get the airport and this little twerp
five foot two pulls me over and he's got
an attitude man he's got short men
syndrome and everything else little
redneck boy and and I sitting there
talking to him I was now second B and he
was a complete chump and he threw my
license back I mean that guy I'll finish
this now you go ahead it's no man for
you listen to this I can feel the heat
competitive right now I'm still gonna go
get that was going too fast I needed
what happened then no I just literally
sent it back in the car and said wow
this rich white man just got treated
this way huh I was like interesting but
again I mean never heard of that
happening before I've never seen it in
my life I've seen me treat be treated
like crap but I haven't I've never seen
a white man be treated
who knew I was gonna be running a
laboratory oh wow we're gonna talk about
one more segment and I think we're not
gonna take calls I'm just enjoying the
conversation I'm not enjoying the
conversation it's a good conversation so
if someone from the black community is
able to read a book by someone from the
white community and quote them and say
that's a good thought
I think it's racism to come at me if I
quote Martin Luther King hmm and I
didn't do anything wrong
I've read the book strength to love
twice and I read a lot about Martin
Luther King because he gave one of the
greatest speeches I'm a speaker
Brene brown does a whole breakdown on
the speech I believe it's Barnea one of
them does a TED talk on the breakdown of
that I have a dream speech and the we've
studied the cadence of it the delivery
from the speaker's perspective it's one
of the greatest recorded speech speeches
of all time and it's not necessarily
studying the content although you have
to get the content to study it but I
mean I can study I can admire and I can
even disagree with you could disagree
with a white person of the past
something that Kennedy said and that
doesn't make you a racist
I can disagree with Martin Luther King
that doesn't make me a racist and to
play that card on stuff like this is not
helpful folks it doesn't help the
discussion
it's unintelligent yeah it's not helpful
the strength to love if again I've read
it twice if you haven't read it
regardless of your color you should but
Martin Luther King was more of a
pacifist than Gandhi and mother Teresa
put together he would have no more
engaged in any kind of violence as a
matter of fact probably you know it's
just a personal opinion and I know there
was a conspiracy to have him killed of
some kind obviously but I mean he didn't
have enough security around him right
because he really just wasn't worried
about it he knew he was going to heaven
and I think he was almost a lamb at the
slaughter he was just
- innocent - passive and I'm not a
pacifist
I get mad I'm like you said a redneck
hillbilly I've used that phrase now I'm
scared about the use of the phrase but
I'm not I'm gonna keep using because it
is Who I am
but but you know I'm that guy and when
in doubt if something needs to be to be
to be punched I punch it I mean I'm not
physically but I mean I would have in
the old days but but you know I'm a
fighter yeah I'm not a pacifist so I had
trouble with strength to love because
I'm not a pacifist but not because of
his skin color right but man the
effectiveness of the civil rights
movement as civil civil the word looked
the bird civil up disobedience was
amazing you can't argue with the results
he pulled off and so I have to stand
back as a warrior type and go this
pacifist I can learn something from it
and that's not a skin color thing that's
a that's a philosophy no difference on
how you approach life yeah and it takes
more strength to be a pacifist than it
does be pissed off guy right it really
does you know he really does I cut and
I'm admitting I'm not as strong that's
what I'm saying yeah but uh that's Jesus
in the garden with Peter saying hey ya
got this yeah I got this I got this I
got this yeah yeah it's okay you don't
have to cut his ear off I got I'm in
control
I got it's okay I got this yeah and I
mean so I I think there's a thing to be
learned with that as well so Anthony
mask you this yeah um you have
absolutely no expertise on this
whatsoever neither do I zero we're just
some guys here talking cuz it's because
it's water color talk water cooler talk
we're all around the water cooler
talking about this this week from your
perspective with your set of knowledge
that I don't have your set up growing up
we're talking about policemen a while
ago yeah and you and I have talked about
this stuff off air many times because
we've learned a lot from each other over
the five years you've been part of this
family
yeah I think it's fair to say I know
your heart that you know that the vast
majority and I don't want whatever
percentage of law enforcement or
excellent people there's ones that
aren't obviously and anyone that can't
recognize both of those things that
there's excellent and it's the vast
majority and
there's some turkey butts and it's some
small percentage if you can't recognize
both of those things and you're being
blocked by your anger and you're not
really thinking clearly because it's
it's an observable fact regardless of
your race but but still there's some
turkey butts and they're executing a
thing that the vast majority of white
people in America the vast majority of
black people in America don't want
thirteen for thirteen point two percent
of the population in America is black
yeah
thirteen percent and yet this number of
young black guys are losing their lives
what do we say to law enforcement how
can how do we help because we want to
respect law enforcement and yet we're
not gonna respect that misbehaviour
agreed yeah absolutely agree and Dave I
cannot afford to hate law enforcement
because my cousin is the commander in
chief of the state trooper in a South
Carolina so that means he's over all of
the state troopers throughout this
entire state of South Carolina and so he
and I have had several conversations in
the past and he admits that there are
bad ones and that he admits that they
need to get rid of them and so I think
for police right now as soon as you see
a sign that they're going down the wrong
way you have to have one proper training
there needs to be some new policies in
place that teach them how to approach
anyone we're going up to the car and
being an African America man especially
African Americans and be sensitive but
protect your life but get rid of the bad
ones because it is you know I was saying
it to my video and uh yesterday Dave
that I've never been fearful being
pulled over by a police officer because
I'm not gonna give any man that much
over me to where I'm fearful of them but
I have been nervous because I do not
know where this can go this and go good
isn't go bad but I've met several great
police officers but I have run into some
some some horrible ones but those
horrible ones do not stop me from loving
and appreciating those who are fighting
for us every single day like my cousin
like one of my good friends here that I
play golf with here in Franklin
Tennessee who was an african-american
police officer and so but I just think
four police officers who are listening
to this
you know what if you see something going
wrong that is going the wrong way
stop it you just got to call it out
because by the way black lives matter
blue lives matter white lives matter
maybe just lives matter yeah you know
that's racist if you say that right no
it's not racist day but you know I think
African Americans they just get upset is
from from the perspective of this that
all lives do matter
we're just saying that at this present
time it's like we need to shine a light
on light on black paper oh no it's like
no it's like so no one's saying all
lives do not matter it's just that it
was someone I know not me I know they're
saying blue lives matter are saying that
cuz they're racist you know but you know
I'm doing you know what I'm talking
right I know what you're talking hey LAN
social media this weekend from people
who don't think yes they and it's wrong
it's wrong it's wrong and one reason we
did this was take up for you
I catch y'all all the time it's just
part of my life but I but I mean what
you've been going through is just
unbelievably wrong oh man you know what
I mean to who much is given much is
required so I'm fighting a good fight
and I'm standing up for what I believe
in Dave and I'm grateful for Bishop TD
jakes says something yes to known as
Instagram yesterday that was so good he
said all lives do matter he said but
we're right now we're talking about that
black man's life that was just taken
oh that's good that's that's that wasn't
because if all live special Bishop can
turn operation he can I say you preach
man you know because I mean everyone
loves each other we just honestly the
african-american community is hurting
and we just want to be hurt and we just
want to be treated equally that's it
you know but I love you I love John I
love everyone in this building me you're
new you know what we feel that way about
our listeners and our tribe and we love
you guys and we're going to be able to
hear to help you
we are not me included Anthony included
gonna be abused by you though you don't
get to tell us what we're gonna do or
how we're gonna act this is who we are
and if you're a white supremacist [ __ ]
and you don't like this we got
- your little pointy head that fits your
little pointy head cap and I know some
of those guys I know most of them have
substandard IQs and if you if you don't
like me doing this show you can kiss my
butt
okay and if you're if you're a black
person and you're mad at me and you're
calling me racist you're just wrong and
I'm not gonna take abuse off that we
love you
we're gonna walk with you we're gonna
help you with your stuff if you want us
to help you if you don't want us to help
you go somewhere else for the help it's
okay but we get it we get it to the
extent we can get it from where we're
coming from and that's a different place
on all of us and this is wrong and it
needs to stop we don't have the
solutions but we want to talk about a
little bit I think the solution is we
start talking about it
and we start listening so we did it one
in the books this is the Dave Ramsey
show